thank you
[Music]
all right this one's gonna get some of
you guys riled up not me dude
it's now starting to come out at the U.S
department of energy and the FBI are uh
are now looking at the lab League
hypothesis of covid being the possible
you know what the [__] pisses me off so
when all this [__] was going down right
like so me and Steve we didn't do
anything but like [__] live stream
and just share like articles with each
other and I'll send us showing different
like I was reading all this [__] with my
family members too they they they're a
lot of them work in healthcare yeah and
some of them were questioning the
administration the hospital
administration's like choices and [__]
like that right so then like I'm getting
all kinds of [__] news from like
traditional media maybe some conspiracy
[__] just I'm just reading as much
material as I can so then I can be like
all right who has incentive in feeding
us lies oh like if are they trying to
make money off this [__] or like or why
why do some hospitals wanna uh inflate
their covet numbers because maybe
they're getting funding from the federal
government for being like covid hurt or
whatever right so like I want to see
motive and I want to see all these
things and see where it all ties
together and I had a lot of [__] time
during lockdown and then
when we started openly talking about it
on JK news hella fans were just like
[__] you guys it's not a lab leak it's
not this and I'm all like how can you be
so goddamn sure because Dr fauci said
dude yeah and you trust everything that
the government tells you and if you
question it you're a conspiracy theorist
don't you like talk about found [__]
like that no no that is enough dude
sorry I've been sitting here the whole
time listen to your rant he's a sweet
Italian man he would never mind us Ryan
and nice and then you [__] kicked me
out of it
sorry sorry that was a nurse at Cedar
cinema at that time and he told me
everybody that was dead that he marked
down as kovit they got 10 G's for yeah
I was like what is the [__] incentive
here so anything if they're like even
pneumonia or [__] leukemia or
whatever it's covered if they can
somehow like just you know bend the
rules just give that dead body covered
real quick before it dies what's the
[__] incense so that's what things
like I was like in the same boat as you
were like whatever we're being fed felt
so [__] fishy and the thing is wait
wait while it was going on you guys had
these doubts yeah yeah
yeah I was I was like believing and I'm
like oh wow that's crazy I was actually
in Europe when all those uh videos of
like Italy where people were [__]
getting like it was like going crazy in
Italy I was actually in Germany at that
time taking the last [__] train back
to like Austria taking the bass back the
last flight back to the U.S it was nuts
when I got into Chicago when I uh uh
they separated us and then the [__]
people in the suits with top to bottom
the Hazmat the Hazmat [__] they were
there waiting for us [__] and it was
all [__] like some stuff was just so
like it was scary and it looked like
they were trying to like but they didn't
know what the [__] they were doing they
had a piece of paper and all we had to
write was which country we came from do
we feel sick yes or no and then we we
give that up they take her temperature
and then we walk in WoW were you messed
up at this time redeem believe it nope
you never mastered we didn't know like
there was it it was during earlier it
was right when covid was happening or
lockdown was happening and all these
countries were shut down oh so they
didn't know the best thing that I did
during covet was probably travel because
in California in California the way it
is it was like remember like to limit
two gallons of milk per household steaks
whatever all that [__] right people were
getting Amazon packages leaving it
outside for 24 hours and they're like
this is me wipe it down and then bring
it inside and then leaving it in the sun
and the window for another like 24 hours
that was California that was me dude
exactly right I go I have to go support
one of my friend had a powerlifting meet
at the gym in Florida so this is my
California ass [__] quadruple Mast
like oh my God am I [__] gonna die
I land in Florida as soon as I get there
everyone's living normal life I'm like
what the [__] people like at a cafe
talking like this chilling
yeah dude
when I walk in everyone turns and looks
at me like I'm weird I'm like oh [__]
I'll take my mask off and I'm just like
observing it
I'm like this is [__] crazy that we
think people more people are dying and
on the other side of the nation they're
living in a completely different way and
I was like this is [__] [__]
that's when I was like what are you sick
did you get sick
what do you mean did you get sick when
you went to the doctor no I got I got
over here
I got covered in California you know
it's like it's not just like all of
California it was mainly LA because if
you go to even [__] Newport Beach
Edwards County yeah yeah everyone's
[__] out in the world dude
I went to Newport Beach and that was a
wild sight to see them I was like whoa
we're out than ever because people knew
that you could go out there or something
like that and I was like holy [__] so I
knew something [__] fishy was going
on so I was like I was like with John I
gotta read anything and everything
because there's an entire side that's
not being portrayed uh I think the best
uh video that I saw that kind of summed
it all up was did you guys see Jon
Stewart's clip yeah where he was saying
he was like amazing the name of the
virus is called the Wuhan whatever virus
right he goes it comes from a lab called
the Wuhan Center of virology he's like
where do you think this virus came
yellow bats yeah yeah he was like it's
literally the name of the [__] virus
yeah and he was like why do we have to
go hmm it's the Wuhan whatever virus but
I'm pretty sure oh no Barba your
conspiracy theorist if it leaks yeah
yeah I was like oh you know it's crazy
too like going back to that like a lot
of people that you were surrounded by
they would like not believe it so hard
but like they were they would get you so
paranoid and scared that you're like
[__] like yeah you're right like this is
kind of [__] scary so like not only
are you getting from the media but
you're getting from everyone else yeah
constantly so you feel like what the
[__] like I can't touch anything people
that didn't even read were making up
[__] or they would hear pieces from the
news and from that point on they didn't
even update their knowledge on anything
so but that's the thing that's the thing
that's tricky though like you reading
what the news says and then you're
reading this other article then which
one is the one that's right
that's the cluster [__] that we're
living in though
but also which one is right and wrong
but also when the news goes all right
kind of different commercial brought to
you by Pfizer you're like oh I mean you
know what I mean when it's like self
advertising its own thing like problem
solution problem solution problem
solution and then this one has no
incentive you're like hmm you know it
makes you kind of take like a couple
steps back like this so for example
right there are um virologists there are
like doctors and stuff that were saying
hold on we shouldn't we're not ready to
like test this out on people yet
that to me is like why would they say
that if they themselves this is their
profession they've been doing it for
over 20 years they that's all they study
is like viruses and all this stuff and
then they're saying hold on guys it's
too early we haven't tested enough it's
not safe
so what were their incentive be to tell
us like they want people to be well they
want people to be protected so there are
groups like that and then they're
getting attacked by the academic
Community by governments and all that so
I'm like well that's weird why would you
do that like the guy that invented the
MRNA vaccine technology he was saying we
need we should hold the I think it's
Robert Malone or something he was like
we should like pump the brakes figure it
out and then everyone is just no we
can't we gotta do it and it was like I
was like oh [__] then he's coming out of
very calm and like these are all backs
or no
but I also know a hell of people that
had to and then just paid off doctors
and got [__] vax cards or like
photoshops and [__] and like who the
[__] really checks that stuff unless
you're like doing like government jobs
or working in a certain way you know I
just did the one shot and then after
that all this I started reading all this
and that's when I was like you know what
[__] it like I don't know and I caught
it too I caught it early on in November
so I was like in basic [__] high
school of biology you learn that if you
catch it you're already immune so I was
like why do I need to get the shot if
I'm already caught it I already have it
I already have a meeting but the Pfizer
one I think that it was like you get the
modern or the Pfizer the Johnson and
Johnson one I got it so I can go to
Hawaii yeah
but I just think it's crazy like it was
like a perfect storm like this viral was
like a perfect storm for like all the
[__] that's happening with social media
and stuff like it just was a virus that
what a time I know he just made
everything like bro who you believe in
is by who you're following on Instagram
yeah that's great what that's who you
[__] can when you meet up with people
and stuff like that and be like oh yeah
like what vaccine did you get you'd be
like oh I got the modernity oh okay cool
what'd you get that I got fights about
ooh lucky what'd you get Johnson Johnson
you all right you know what I mean that
was just a thing though you know but
going back to what you said I I didn't
start to feel like normal until I
started listening to like certain
virologists or like actual professors
talk about just like the overall scopes
of like how diseases work and like just
basic mechanisms where I'm like oh okay
we're gonna be fine you know like until
I started listening to basic
understanding of virus disease and I
think the world was freaking out too
because they didn't know we lived among
so much germs viruses bacteria on a
constant basis so I think it made
everybody a germaphobe for sure and it's
like it's been like that full yeah what
are you talking about also if you study
history right and if you see how I'm
sorry I was scared this guy's coughing
on me what the [__] did you see how you
see how pandemics work right or like if
you see in the past the plagues that
we've been through one of the most
um telling signs or the most vulnerable
populations that are in bad hygienic
like States will be dropping yeah I
didn't see any homeless people dropping
dead like all over skid row that was my
first sign too I was like if this is
even healthier they would have died yeah
it's only first world Nations that were
dying so it's a cool comorbidity it was
all diabetic people diabetic people
overweight people nobody explains that
like and like I think it's on the
messaging of the
faucially yeah
what the disease is about no but it's
like they don't explain that stuff so
then we're all like left to make money
if they explain exactly but exactly
that's the thing right it's like and
then we're able to make up our own
narratives and then we're listening to
[__] Joe schmoe from down the block
and we're listening from like just
different family members have their
Peace of Mind of like uh what coven's
really about so then you hear all these
different points of views and then
you're like you like when you said like
who the [__] do we listen to bro I can't
wait five years from now seeing the
documentary on Netflix about this [__]
and they're like oh my God yeah and then
they're just gonna start shaming all the
people that like got [__] vaccines
and stuff but I did get some really cool
face masks over the pandemic sick ass
face masks like I got some like some
cool Brands like that's tight it's just
crazy how now that now it's now that the
US and the FBI is admitting that oh this
really could be the like the FBI admits
with mine [__] are all those people that
were like
conspiracy all these [__] have
amnesia that they were so they were like
we don't know what you're talking about
I feel like I feel like that type of
stuff needs to be said because if not it
would be Mayhem
that type of like conversation needs to
be out there because if people don't
think it's a conspiracy you don't have
time to chill and be like wait yeah and
they just go off of like look what
happened with the water they had to
start being like hey everybody calm down
this might be crazy this might be you
know we gotta calm people a little bit
down even if it's a lie I think that the
lie was needed because if not people
would just go [__] crazy yeah and
start becoming Wild Wild West oh like
the toilet paper and stuff you know what
I'm saying I'm saying like if you're the
[__] president bro like you would
have to or if your your dad and the kids
you got to learn how to AI a little bit
to the kids before you figure out what's
happening you know what I mean you got
to tell the kids like no no no the
boat's not drowning it's just it's just
we're letting a little water a little
like air out yeah and you're just like
look at the water in so we can play but
you guys can play with it inside okay
cool we're [__] playing together and
as the parents are like how are we gonna
fix this [__] hole
sweetie how the [__] this is [__]
drowning right now and if they can't let
the kids know because if they freak out
it's gonna make things worse I don't
know sometimes I feel like if you're in
that position I think lies need to I
think especially when you're putting
something in everybody's bodies though
right I mean it was just water they said
we think the Cure under this like still
alive pandemic was caused by Postmates
big Postmates and [__] big Uber Eats
so so so so if you want to go crazy we
want to go [__] Amazon to ubereats it
was Amazon they made a [__] ton of the
person that benefited from this Amazon
came the [__] up bro Amazon came up hard
[Music]
thank you
foreign